aujourd'hui dans l'actu le premier jour
de l'Open de France de golf sur le site
du Golf National de 50 ans en Yvelines
nous verrons également pourquoi les
entreprises et l'université par exemple
font le choix qui est installé des
stands sport et business font parfois
bon ménage vous êtes étudiant et vous
recherchez peut-être un logement pour la
rentrée de septembre nous faisons le
point sur la situation dans
l'agglomération et nous verrons comment
des nouvelles solutions d'hébergement
peuvent se mettre en place pour
accompagner les entreprises qui veulent
se développer à l'exportation la CCI
lance le Club International Evelyne le
témoignage de Pascal Pelletier PDG d'une
société qui réalise 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires à l'étranger et puis c'est
aujourd'hui la dernière journée de
classe des enfants à la sortie d'une
école à Montigny-le-Bretonneux première
impression des petits vacanciers
l'Open de golf Alstom 2012 au Golf
National 50 ans en Yvelines c'est parti
alors on le voit derrière la fiche
derrière moi la question est évidemment
qui détrônera Thomas levait le tenant du
titre diminué après deux blessures en
2011 et 2012 parmi ses concurrents
sérieux on retrouve le numéro 3 mondial
l'Anglais Lee Westwood et son
compatriote leader de la race to Dubaï
Justin rose mais à l'Open de golf Alstom
il n'y a pas que le sport c'est
également l'occasion pour certains de
communiquer regardez
toutes les marques ont des partenariats
avec l'européenne tours d'une part donc
ce sont les marques références et après
ils doivent obligatoirement également
avoir un contrat avec le promoteur donc
l'Alstom Open de France ao cette année
je pense qu'il y a un engouement autour
du Golf National et de ce parcours qui
est Ryder Cup donc il y a beaucoup de
marques qui font le choix d'investir en
termes de marketing de venir au golf
national ce qui était pas le cas tout le
temps parmi ces marques diverses
enseignes de luxe dont une célèbre
marque de montres qui profitent de
l'événement pour inviter ses clients
fidèles et séduire de nouveaux acheteurs
on avait des invités qui ont parc qui
ont pu jouer avec de grands champions
donc ils étaient tellement contents sont
des clients qu'on avait au sein de notre
de notre petite entreprise et voilà les
connaissent les autres et ainsi de tout
le monde se parle c'est sympathique
c'est sympathique et puis s'ils veulent
se faire plaisir
après c'est un ensemble mais au moins
déjà c'est une belle vitrine c'est une
très jolie vitrine mais il n'y a pas que
des grands noms du on retrouve également
à l'Open Alstom l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin invité par la Communauté
d'Agglomération nous avons eu l'idée que
ça pouvait être intéressant d'être
présent sur cet événement qu'une
certaine couverture médiatique et un
moment opportun pour rencontrer dans un
contexte plus convivial nos partenaires
bien établi avec lequel nous avons des
relations sur la recherche sur la
formation également pour nouer de
nouveaux partenariats industriels
économique largement et aussi c'est
l'occasion pour permettre à certains
nombre de collègues de collaborateurs de
partager à un moment de détente dans un
cadre très sympathique coup de
l'emplacement UVSQ à l'Open de golf
selon Jean-Luc Veyssière 40 000 euros
chaque année sur les 2000 demandes de
logement qui arrivent au CROUS de
Versailles 16% aboutissent alors même si
4 nouvelles résidences universitaires
devraient ouvrir d'ici 2013 pour les
étudiants trouver un logement relève des
12 travaux d'Hercule c'est pour cela que
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
a ouvert il y a 6 mois un service
consacré au logement Delphine Arnold
chef de ce service à la rue de tâches
d'informer ses protégés et trouver des
propriétaires acceptant de louer à des
étudiants on est en train de travailler
donc avec la communauté d'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sur un
projet de plateforme commune on aurait
une base de données en fait de logement
de propriétaire privé qu'on a créé sur
internet un portail qui est destiné aux
propriétaires donc où il pleuve
retrouver notamment une foire aux
questions qui leur permettra de répondre
aux questions qui peuvent se poser s'ils
veulent louer à des étudiants certains
propriétaires lou volontiers une partie
de leur maison à des étudiants Michel
trivic a sauté le pas l'année dernière
il a pris contact avec une association
et à héberger pendant 10 mois une
étudiante américaine je dirais que le
but principal quand on le fait c'est pas
il y a pas l'aspect pécunier évidemment
bon il y a des frais mais c'est
évidemment un échange qu'on peut avoir
d'autres avec d'autres personnes une
personne culture différente d'une
religion différente d'origine différente
ce qui permet à nos enfants mais
finalement découvrir à travers cette
personne son pays ses origines sa
famille ses amis aujourd'hui la chambre
est vide mais la famille garde des
contacts réguliers avec celles qui a
partagé leur vie une expérience que
Michel trivic souhaite renouveler
cependant les offres spontanées de
bâiller étudiants sont rares et malgré
les programmes d'aide au logement comme
le locapass une caution publique ou le
GRM une assurance contre les loyers
impayés loués à des personnes à faible
ressources comme les étudiants fait
encore peur
bonjour mesdames bienvenue à la ville de
78 suivez-moi je vais vous recevoir
alors l'université collabore avec l'ADIL
l'agence sur le logement qui donne des
conseils gratuits à tous les
particuliers en matière juridique
fiscales et financières le conseil que
je donnerais à ce propriétaire c'est de
faire un bail de 9 mois un bail étudiant
qui lui permet en fait de louer ce
logement pendant 9 mois uniquement neuf
mois le bail n'est pas reconductible ce
qui lui permettra soit de refaire un
contrat de location avec cet étudiant si
l'expérience lui a plu soit d'arrêter là
en plus de conseiller des particuliers
la DEAL informe le public en participant
à des forums vous pourrez notamment les
rencontrer lors du premier forum sur le
logement étudiant organisé par
l'Université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce samedi dans
les locaux à Guyancourt
Pascal Pelletier PDG d'une société de
lutte contre les risques incendies il
compte 18 salariés 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires est faite à l'export sa
société est implantée au Maroc et ses
débuts ont démarré au Sénégal selon lui
se développer à l'international ce n'est
pas forcément facile pas difficile très
difficile d'abord c'est d'abord ce qu'il
faut c'est surtout ne pas arriver en
conquérant vous savez la France a été
une grande grande nation à l'exportation
elle a été très représentée très
représentative aujourd'hui elle a perdu
son aura parce que beaucoup d'autres
pays aussi font de l'export c'est clair
c'est un combat permanent beaucoup de
modestie une expérience qui a intéressé
la Chambre de commerce elle vient de
lancer le Club International Evelyne
pour proposer des formations aider les
chefs d'entreprise dans leur démarche
administrative pour Pascal Peltier un
accompagnement indispensable c'est pas
le tout d'aller partout et nulle part
finalement après ce qui est important
c'est la notion économique et de et de
savoir organiser son développement
savoir se faire aider il y a eu France
il y a évidemment la Chambre de commerce
il y a la Coface ce chef d'entreprise a
pu compter sur un suivi individualisé ce
qui selon lui lui a permis un
développement exponentiel aujourd'hui le
taux de croissance de sa PME s'établit
entre 25 et 30% par an dans les Yvelines
et le Val-d'Oise 4200 entreprises sont
exportatrices 400 d'entre elles
bénéficient déjà d'un accompagnement à
l'international
il danse sur le parvis de la mairie de
Magny-les-Hameaux une flashmob la
première du genre dans la commune
proposée par un animateur de la ville et
pour se faire ces danseurs d'un jour ont
été avertis via les réseaux sociaux
et David lui ségliglio prévoit une autre
flash mob l’année prochaine et il
promène plus large participation
c'est un jour particulier pour toi
aujourd'hui c'est quoi alors dis-moi
le dernier jour d'école
et tu vas faire quoi en Chine alors
tout ça à Toulon
de glace qui est plus parti
je vais aller à la mer
je veux rester avec ma maman
et tu vas faire quoi tu vas faire des
cahiers de te voir faire des révisions
c'est la fin de l'année et l'année
prochaine on va au collège
est-ce que tu as un peu peur d'aller au
collège comment ça se passe dans ta tête
d'être en vacances